hi everyone thanks so much for joining
our talk today
the talk is titled enter the ecosystem
affecting the digital transformation of
biospecific interactions through dmf
webtech and a bucket of algorithms
my name's soleil and adam will be
joining us for the second half of the
presentation
we're both product managers at nakoya
life sciences which is a biotechnology
company located
in kitchener ontario canada that's
focused on building solutions for
users who want to measure biomolecular
interactions
so the agenda and breakdown of the day
so obviously we're going to focus on all
of the ways that we've infused
automation
into the measurement of biospecific
interactions with our platforms
so the first thing we're going to do is
just talk about the researcher journey
with the data type
and i'm going to sort of orient everyone
on what it is that we actually build
so that by the time adam starts talking
about how we automate that
we're all on the same page so the second
through six points are really going to
look at the steps of the user journey
so designing your assay actually
executing the experiment
looking at the analysis and then really
zeroing in on what those results mean
and finally we're going to have a little
bit more forward-looking fun
where we talk about some solutions that
are coming to you soon
and so as we enter the ecosystem which
is really just a term that we use for
the solutions that we provide our users
and the ecosystem in which our users use
those solutions
um what they're really looking at is the
biospecific interactions
so as you can see below biomolecules are
typically reacted in pairs
in some condition and our users want to
answer questions about the strength
specificity and speed of interactions
and why might they want to do that
so all of human physiology is basically
one big
binding party everything that happens
whether it's a disease mechanism of
action
um just a typical run-of-the-mill
reaction in your body
um or the way that we understand how a
drug interacts with a potential target
these are all predicated on binding
events
and so at nakoya as i mentioned we build
platforms
which basically just means an instrument
great software
and consumables to enable our users to
measure these biospecific interactions
and so everything
that we're trying to do is really trying
to mimic
in some kind of way a physiological
environment and one of the things that
you need for that
is some kind of microfluidic system that
delivers samples
to a sensor and so one of the things
that's really revolutionary about what
we're doing at nikoia
is that we use a liquid handling
technology called digital microfluidics
and this sounds a little scary but it's
really not it's
just a way of manipulating nanoliter
size droplets
using an electrode and so basically what
you do
is you have an electrode array
underneath the droplets which are
suspended
in a cartridge fluid or a medium and
these droplets are attracted to when
voltage is applied to an electrode
so you can see that's highlighted on the
left when things are red so when those
individual electrodes are red
we're representing that they are engaged
and that brings the droplet somewhere
now we can also split mix merge droplets
but the important thing for our users
is that we can bring the samples to the
sensor
in a way which gets them great data
which is shown on the right hand side
so there's some fancy algorithms that
are applied but really what we're
looking at is a time versus response
and that's what dmf enables us to see is
what is happening at the sensor surface
with a myriad of different types of
reagents and sample droplets that are
brought to the sensor tip
and so how does this actually look on
the cartridge so this is our liquid
handling technology those are these
dispenses so after something is
dispensed from a well which you pipetted
into
they're brought into the mixing zone and
we can perform automated serial
dilutions
on the cartridge itself after which the
samples are brought up to the sensor
and we expect to acquire our data if
there's a binding event
happening at the sensor and how do we
know if there's a binding event
actually happening at the sensor or not
well
this is where we get our signal so in
our take on the technology
we use digital microfluidics to move the
reactants
and the reagents necessary to get good
data to and from a fiber optic based
sensor
and these sensors use a phenomenon
called lspr or localized surface plasmon
resonance which utilizes
nanoparticles as a substrate on a fiber
optic tip
and what this does is essentially enable
us to measure changes in mass at the
surface in real time
and so what you're seeing is a shift in
absorbance and what our users see
which is important to them is a
magnitude shift in the response at the
sensor which would
indicate that binding event actually
occurring in real time
without the use of labels
so what do our users want to know about
this data type so they understand that
there's a response happening which is
representative of the change of mass
and then they understand that there is
some time progression that occurs
throughout the experiment
but the first and most important thing
is specificity is there actually an
attraction between these two
biomolecules
and if so does it depend on the
experimental conditions
the second thing is the strength so how
strong is this interaction
and typically this is reported as kd or
affinity
um but for us it's really the ratio of
the association so the forward rate
constant and the reverse
rate constant and so that's how we
acquire our kd
the great thing about spr versus typical
endpoint assays is that you actually
understand how quickly that interaction
happens
so both on the association and
dissociation side because we are seeing
these events in real time
we're able to understand how quickly
they come together and how long it takes
for them to dissociate or come apart
and so how do our researchers reason
about their work with our platform
basically they start with some
biological question does a
bind to b and if so how strongly and if
so how quickly do they come together
and how long does it take for them to
dissociate so the second thing they
would do is design their assay
so you know you'll have one binding
partner on that sensor
they'll have another in solution and
adam's going to talk about this in a
little bit more detail
but i'll leave it at that high level for
now and then this assay design that they
build in our software
it gets mapped to the biosensor and the
biosensor really is meant to do the work
for you
and finally we get our results that's
where things are analyzed
we have some really cool ways of
automating this analysis process step
which can
take a little bit of time as you're
running through a lot of different
experiments
and so just zeroing in on that biosensor
step i thought it might be helpful
to look at how this works so they
designed their assay on the
software itself that is then shared
through the cloud to the instrument
and the instrument is then um outputting
the data back to the cloud into the
analysis software
so the niko system is our user portal
where both the design
and the results live and users can
easily interact and exchange between the
two
so the device operation itself we really
try to automate as many of the steps as
possible which means
reducing the hands-on time as much as
possible
so let's just take a look at what
happens here
so like i said we produce a platform
which is an instrument a software
and a consumable which you see being
open on the screen
and this consumable is what we call a
cartridge
and a cartridge is basically just a
container for sensors
and your different reagents and that's
where
you can see the little electrodes that
actually are able to move the reagents
that you pipet into
and now we're opening the cartridge
fluid which is the medium in which
the samples are suspended as well as
your reagents
and so you simply open up this tube
and you place it into the cartridge and
it automatically dispenses evenly
throughout the entire cartridge
and again this is building the medium in
which you will pipet your samples into
and that makes it so dmf is able to
apply the voltage
to bring your samples from where you
pipetted them up to the sensors that are
closer to the top of the cartridge
and now we're looking at our sample map
so after we designed our experiment
also tells you exactly where to put what
sample
and this will depend on when you want
that sample to go to the sensor and how
you want it to be treated as it travels
to the sensor
do you want to perform automated serial
dilutions on it or do you just want it
to go straight to the sensor
is it a buffer is it a regen solution
all of these things are programmed into
the experiment itself so by the time you
get here you're just following a sample
map
and inputting the different reagents
and then you start and also closes its
door and your experiment is executed
from there
so we truly tried to build a walk-up
instrument that was extremely
user-friendly
and now i'm going to pass it over to
adam to sort of unpack the user journey
for us
and look at each of the different steps
and how we thought about
automating each of those steps so thanks
and i will hand it over to you adam
awesome thanks elaine um so
this next section we're going to talk
about how we are automating the first
part of the user journey which is
when we are designing assays and mapping
them
uh to all the different bits and pieces
that need to run behind the scenes
um to kind of organize information that
we get from the user
and group things into
pieces of repeat work that the device
needs to perform
so when we're speaking about everything
that happens on the device we've
designed around by
uh the particular problems that our
users face in performing bio-specific
interactions
so just a couple helpful terms that we
can review today um that we're going to
generalize
for this discussion when possible so
bi-specific
interactions are comprised of two or
more reactants
one introduced from the surface and one
from solution
there's usually a condition involved
this is the environment in which the
interaction takes place
right this is a biophysical
characterization technique so
temperature matters um anything else
involved in the interaction matters like
the ph
the ionic strength of the reactions
environment
and any kind of cofactors there's some
jargon that sneaks in here
um in this particular industry there's
the ligand that's basically what we call
the molecule that's on the surface of
the sensor
um that we need to kind of stick around
while we bring in another molecule to
react with it
then there's the analyte this is the
solution reactant this is what comes in
in the drop
that we want to react with the molecule
that we've captured onto the surface of
our sensor
so we've looked at our main interaction
components putting it all together here
um you've got the solution sample the
surface sample
and then the condition this is the
environment in which the reaction
is performed um so
any reaction that we perform on a device
like this or any other
can be described as a matrix in and
dimensions so
a single interaction requires us to
deliver a specific sequence of drops to
a sensor
which includes one of our reactants
there's a lot of different things that
we're trying to do on this device
sometimes we're trying to put something
onto the surface of a sensor sometimes
we're trying to react something with it
and other times we're just trying to
modify the environment in which the
reaction occurs
um we are conditioning the uh the
molecules on the surface or performing
some other action like that
or allowing them to stabilize over time
pretty much all of these behaviors
can be described as sequences of drops
basically the steps
that we need to perform for any type of
activity that we perform on the device
so a couple examples here what we do is
we allow our user to describe their
experiment
as simply as possible so for example i
have m surface reactants and n
solution reactants in this
figure here you can see that we've got
our
m and n those are the numbers of things
that we're trying to react which defines
this matrix
which we then scale often times by
concentration so that's already three
dimensions
that we need to accommodate um on this
particular device
in addition to all the other ones that
we can scale from here for example like
we mentioned
ph ionic strength and so on
um and then you can see and kind of our
first example of the
the output data type which is the
sensogram uh and a helpful
uh visualization across the top of the
sensogram which is the drop timeline so
you can see the drops arriving on a
particular sensor
and then the output signal from that
sensor
some pretty common topologies that we
encounter in these matrices can
sometimes be described as one on many
many on one but very commonly many on
many and these are just a couple
examples of what our researchers deal
with so
and the one on the left here we have a
lot of different reactants coming in
from solution
and then we have one for example a
particular protein that we want to react
with
that we're going to place on the sensor
surface
then in the next example here in the
middle you can see that we have just a
few
um reactants from the solution phase but
we have many that we want to place
on the surface of the sensors um the
reasons for doing this we won't get into
in this particular conversation but they
often have to do with valency
and the stability of the molecules that
we're working with and finally on the
right hand side you can see
there are very many um in this case
compounds that we're introducing
to a few uh proteins that we've put
on sensor surfaces
so we can basically extend this
framework to accommodate any interaction
system a user is interested in with just
a few inputs
right we've described how many things we
want to react
from the solution phase how many things
we need to put on a surface
and then any other conditions that might
be involved so what this does is it
tells
us how many unique sensor addresses we
need it tells us how many unique
wells or physical addresses we need to
put unique samples
into a cartridge or across many
cartridges in an experiment
and it also tells us how many conditions
we need to add into the cartridge so
and total volumes that we need to
accommodate overall
so this is the the basic framework that
allows us to kind of scale
any any experiment that the user could
possibly design around this data type
and we've built tools that allow users
to expressively
describe what they want to do on our
devices you can see here on
the left hand side some assay templates
and things like that
for selection and on the right hand side
the basic
inputs and forms that a user has
to help define what they're trying to do
experimentally
this is a figure i particularly like um
so the left hand side
is the tools that our users have to work
with in software but on the right hand
side we're visualizing how the data
structure scales behind the scenes
based on what the user's trying to do so
our software takes all of this
information
and we've designed algorithms that help
the user get the most out of the
hardware that they're working with right
a lot of times things can be done in
parallel other times it's better to do
things serially
it just depends what the user is trying
to do and we build algorithms to
accommodate all of that
so as we map the data to the hardware
this is
the final and really important step of
this stage
in assay design where we need to not
only
set up what happens on a single
cartridge but very often the
experiment that a user has in mind
might require more than one for example
input
traditionally but in this case because
our entire biosensor is basically
defined by the cartridge um they their
experiment might need to scale over
multiple cartridges and so our
algorithms accommodate that as well
you can see in this example we're
scaling as we
uh tweak the dials here and define our
experiment
you can see its scale within one
cartridge depending what you're just
doing and then over multiple cartridges
to our ecosystem this is still one
experiment
but it has already been broken up into
multiple methods that can be run
on a single device in series or across
multiple devices if you have them in
parallel
all of the data will be analyzed in
pieces as
it is available but the final report can
be generated
from the set in aggregate
okay so that's how we automate the assay
design
now we're going to talk about how we
automate experiment execution
so this is one of the the coolest pieces
of this technology and all the work that
we've seen so far in automation
um it really is enabled um
by these techniques that we're going to
talk about here so the first piece
is we need to break down our experiments
into activities this is a
logical model that we are a logical
grouping
that we use to describe uh work that is
performed routinely
across many different experiments so
very often we're trying to build a
surface
for example we want to put molecules on
the surface of our sensor sensors
and in this case um
you can see here we've just got
basically the most simple
activity you can possibly think of where
we've got one
molecule on surface reacting with one in
solution and we've got
what we would call our interaction
object and associated results
here on the right
so that's high level what the user wants
to know right they want kinetics right
and that's an activity designed to get
them kinetics
um within an activity we need to perform
a number of drop sequences so this is an
example of
what a full experiment would look like
um where we've got the activities across
the top and you can kind of see the
the hierarchy of our data structure the
cycles that we group them into
the sequences and then the sensors that
those sequences are assigned to
right and so if you kind of look at the
insets here you can see
here's still our simple one to one or
one um
reactant in solution one reactant on the
surface
model but you can see all of the steps
that are required
to perform this basically right you can
see all of the five sequences
uh grouped into the five cycle sorry the
the two sequences per cycle required
to generate the data um and have a
reference channel
basically um and then you can also see
the surface building steps and a couple
other
um you know support activities like
normalizing the cartridge
and cleaning the sensors
all right this is the coolest part i
think of the technology um
everything that we're doing um is
basically we've we've quantized this
entire data type right so
there is a discrete unit in
involved for every different step that
we need the device perform
so everything basically breaks down into
drops
so here we have an example of
the five different drop types and i
don't think you can see them let me see
if i can move this
screen there you go so
you can see here we've identified five
major drop rolls
so anything that the user puts in the
cartridge probably falls into one of
these five categories
in terms of the experiments and what
that solution is going to be used for
um so i'm just going to move this back
right here
there we go okay and you can see this
example here where
like we saw earlier we're moving drops
towards the sensor
in order to execute that drop sequence
so you can see the drop sequence
executing here and you can see the data
being made available in real time as the
drops are addressing the sensor
unfortunately i did not have time to
synchronize this figure
so they're a little out of sync but you
get the idea if you let this cruise for
a little while
all right so let's keep on rolling here
all right so all of all of these uh core
behaviors
are enabled by dmf so what can dmf do
for us
um the first thing that we can do on our
devices is dispense that's where we
take from a common reservoir some uh
number of drop units and dispense them
onto the transport layer
now drop unit is around 300 nanoliters
um and so
we can distribute that volume or you
know larger trains of drops
of many drop units around the cartridge
the next step is moving them once we've
dispensed into the transport layer the
main operation on the cartridge is
really just moving drops around the
electrode map
and finally we can split drops you can
see in this figure we've got a two drop
unit that we're splitting
into um two drops uh one
drop unit each basically all right so
some advanced operations
um we've got shake so sometimes we need
to mix a drop
or you know to introduce good transport
conditions we want molecules
to get to the sensor surface so that
they can react so a lot of times we try
to
induce good transport conditions to
minimize the height of the boundary
layer by
oscillating them on the surface of our
sensors
then sometimes we also need to mix
things together this is super helpful on
device
for mixing uh activating reagents that
have a
short half-life once mixed their short
working time we
need to use them as quickly as possible
so that's another useful operation that
we have on device
and then super advanced operations are
these choreographed
subroutines right so let's say we need
to perform an automated illusion
where the user actually needs to
introduce a train of drops to the sensor
surface
and in this drop sequence they need a
you know serial or geometric dilution
series right
um and in this case we can actually you
can see
we're introducing a stock concentration
we've arranged
the stock concentration and then the set
of five uh buffer drops so
no concentration equals zero and we're
just kind of passing along
a one drop unit to all these two drop
unit drops which performs a three-fold
elution series which is perfect
for performing kinetics and that's
exactly the type of thing that
certainly um from a a
personal experience try not to think
about how many times i've
how much time i've spent making dilution
series so this is something really cool
that the device can do
for users ad hoc
all right um
one more thing to talk about here is
that
all of this that we've just looked at
all of these cool dmf subroutines
and the framework for how we talk about
the hardware
as sets of our maps of sensors
and a transport layer and a sample layer
with a bunch of unique addresses to put
unique reagents in this experiment
description
as a set of drop sequences that are
arranged in cycles and activities
and so on um this is a platform that we
can build on
so we have a ton of freedom on this
device to continue to make new
cartridges
and fundamentally um adapt to
specific applications but nothing really
changes
around these core uh you know the core
engineering of the device
so we still have an instruction set we
still have a cartridge map
and we still have an experiment so what
we can do is is
with this information we can calculate
all of the
the electro wedding commands that we
need to perform the experiment
which is very cool um and which you
might consider an ahead of time
or aot compilation technique when it
comes to electro wetting
a big question that some of you are
already asking i'm sure
is can this device be programmed to make
decisions in real time
there are lots of scenarios where let's
say you have a concentration
but you don't know you don't rather you
have an interaction you need to perform
but you're not sure what the kd is
um what concentration do you use
typically you would optimize and you'd
try it first and then you would kind of
figure it out and then you try to
bracket the kd or you just run
everything
with like a uh you know at least a high
concentration just kind of see what you
get and then maybe tweak it later and
rerun things
or let's say um you run something and
you didn't quite optimize the
regeneration condition and so you've got
incomplete regeneration
you know what do you do right um can the
device help you out in these situations
of course the answer is absolutely yes
as you might have guessed um this is
very much the promise of digital
microfluidics
combined with optical biosensing so we
call this
um there's a lot of uh terms here but
we'll just call it a kind of uh advanced
scheduling or dynamic scheduling what
that means is
we're able to um use this kind of
dynamic discrete event simulation
routine
to take what needs to happen in context
with what has happened
and figure out what needs to happen next
right so
a lot of the problems that this helps us
solve specific to
our current users in the optical
biosensor space
precision target signals right a target
has reached do something
target is not achieved do something else
for example like time out and or give up
um affinity estimations um let's say
we're able to make one really quickly
with just like a quick drop
addressed to the the sensor surface um
we can very easily from there
estimate a kd right um and then
perfectly br choose the concentrations
needed to bracket
and uh basically generate perfect sensor
grams um smart off rate detection right
if we're really looking to guarantee
five percent
decay in our off rate or if we don't
want to waste
a bunch of time on a particular
interaction
um dissociating when we don't really
need to we've got plenty of decay in
order to fit an accurate off rate
that's another situation where this
dynamic scheduling is
super helpful and finally problem sensor
detection let's say we have a sensor
that gets fouled
happens all the time when you're working
with novel compounds
that sensor typically you would just you
know let the experiment continue
after the fact identify problem sensors
or problem spots within
within a run and then rerun those
compounds let's say you could identify
it in real time
and re-cue those samples to a good
sensor
so that you don't have to stop the
experiment and by the time the
experiment finishes
you are guaranteed to have good data so
that these are situations in which um
the dynamic scheduling that is enabled
by the digital microfluidics
really helps our users out and
automating a lot of processes
finally there's the operation the device
itself we've talked a lot about what
actually happens
inside the machine within the context of
a single experiment
um but let's let's talk a little bit
more about um a solution that we've
designed for
um you know scaling experiments outside
of what we can do
inside of a single cartridge um we've
got a salute a collection or a cluster
of three robots here we've got the alto
we've got a standard pf400 and we've got
an opentron the liquid handler
um and so what this setup allows us to
do is
request cartridges right alto can say
hey opentrons make this cartridge for me
and it knows what's in the open trons
and also
it can control the environment of the
samples not only in the alta device
itself but also in the opentrons because
they have a lot of nice modules
for you know for example sample chillers
and things like that
that can help us maintain the
environment of samples outside of
the alto itself loading and removing
cartridges
storing multiple cartridges that might
be needed across a large run
pipetting samples like we just talked
about into the cartridges and basically
operating itself so in this way alto
can talk to you know these other robots
in this cluster
and get exactly what it needs to work
through a large experiment
um or multiple experiments um in a queue
and then finally final point in this
section is that we
absolutely recognize that machines are
users too a lot of the most exciting
work i think in drug discovery is coming
from these automated workflows and
platforms in biophysical
characterization so
we absolutely have plan support for this
fully automated uh
environment both from experiment
creation to device operation like we
just showed you
all the way through analysis with our
nikoi apis
all right so now the really fun part um
this you know to a lot of users is the
product certainly if you're not in the
lab operating the devices
this is what you'll see out of this
platform as you'll you'll see data
and so we've engineered some fully
automated best effort
analysis techniques for across our
application landscape
and this is all supported by our cloud
architecture so if you look at
the figure on the right here oh well
ignore what's under there it's basically
just our devices
in a little little row all this is
the takeaway here is that there are you
know two web or a main web app that we
use to host
our analysis tools our design tools our
some dashboards to help users you know
see what's going on on all of their
devices
and support tools and
this is where we um
host a lot of our analytical techniques
but um
we have also i'll talk about that in a
moment
let's first talk about the data
structure so corridor data structure are
these data drops and interaction objects
um this helps us get data where it needs
to go and is ultimately highly
composable
you can see that we collect data at the
drop level so every time a drop is in
contact with the sensor
we are collecting data um on that
interaction
so we at the end of an experiment we
have
a bucket of drops we can arrange those
drops
based on what the experiment did into
these interactions
which are usually experiment specific
sometimes if we're looking at qc
we'll want to be looking at a particular
drop in every sequence let's say we
really want to look at baseline
over the course of an experiment we can
look at all the buffer drops every time
buffer was in contact
historically over an experiment with a
sensor
we can group all those together and very
easily look at those
without having to you know look at other
things that may not be
related to it but if we're looking at
interactions for sure we're looking at
these kind of like baseline drops as you
can see on the right
the solution sample and then usually
that dissociation phase
where we're looking at the decay and the
interaction we can group
everything together based exactly on
what we need
and then perform further analyses from
there
everything that we do in the
analysis tools is kind of best effort at
first approach so
what this means is as a user when you
log into the portal
if an experiment is complete your
results are immediately available
we of course provide all of these
different views that you see here to
allow you to go in and tweak data
and continue to explore it and
you know re-analyze it as necessary but
we also
do the best we can to design the
software
to direct you to anything that needs
your attention right so you can filter
and group by lots of different tags
um the good data obviously you
probably don't need to interact with but
certainly if there's problematic data
that you might want to try to salvage or
use in some way
that the software is is unable to or you
know recommends against
you still have the freedom to do that um
all of this is built upon a
classification and tagging system
this is super exciting um so if you are
not
into data science you probably work with
the data science group i'm sure
um and certainly they will
uh have a lot of things to say about
this but um we basically
um have multiple tags available for
every kind of experimental feature those
are the interactions themselves
the samples things that you know are you
care about
um from the experiment perspective as
well as system features so sensors
again let's say a sensor gets fouled
that's something that you might want to
know but is based on
the sensor itself then right and not the
actual interactions
um and then wells drop paths things like
that
um and this is kind of an example you
can see on the left here
um a couple simple tags um this is a
regeneration qc
it looks like and then on over here
we've got some kinetic analyses
and a lot of different classifications
as well for uh biphasic interactions
um non-binding any anything that we can
help you identify we will do
and you can of course overwrite and
redefine the classifications as needed
um in the same set of tools
um really briefly today just wanted to
introduce a couple simple things around
some application specific modules um
just to let you know what's coming
um as we release more and more tools i
think that's one of the the coolest
things about this
web-based analysis package is it makes
it very easy for us to continue to push
new features
to our users and help them get more out
of the machines
so these are a couple examples of some
epitope characterization
tools that we have coming out um
and a lot of you know we have
purpose-built data visualizations
and you know again tools that to try to
help you get
the most out of your sensograms and
finally
the last point to note on how we're
automating analysis is that
all of the tools that we make available
um to support the web app are also
available on device
um so it's an npm package that probably
doesn't mean anything to
most people here but um we it can run on
the device it runs in the cloud it can
run anywhere our data goes
basically so on the device especially in
real time we can analyze data
and make help the device makes decisions
in this case the device is telling us
that
looks like an affinity is likely single
digit nanomolar that's great um
the off rate looks pretty fast and we
have a one micromolar stock in the
cartridge
so the device in this case can make a
decision
to start off at 300 nanomolar and
perform a 3x resolution
over five points and that should
perfectly bracket the kd based on that
input information which is a lot of the
information that you might have done
in a lengthy kind of optimization
process
and then over here on the right uh we've
got our
a little some notifications saying that
analysis is available because an
experiment completed on the device
um as soon as it's done on the device
you know that in the cloud and it looks
like
um there are a couple interactions that
need review and it's letting us know
that as well
finally automating results getting data
where it needs to go
i don't have a lot to share at this
stage but all of this
is being built into our nokoya apis we
have
planned out a rest api and data services
that can help our users
get data where it needs to go let's say
you're you know
you've built out an automated uh
characterization pipeline and you need
whenever an experiment finishes you want
to set up a trigger
to go and fetch that data or just the
interactions
objects or whatever you need from that
experiment to feed your data pipeline
these apis will help you do that
securely and
get it get your data wherever it needs
to go
as well as set up experiments and a
couple other cool features that we'll
talk about in a future presentation
so welcome to the ecosystem this is a
digitally transformed platform for
discovery
with optical biosensor data
that's awesome thank you adam and thanks
so much everyone for joining us today
um this concludes our overview of an
ecosystem and the effect
that digital microfluidics brings to
optical biosensors
for those of you who find yourself
studying biomolecular interactions and
are looking to transform your journey
with label-free biosensors
we invite you to join our growing base
of ecosystem users
for any questions about today's
presentation you can reach us via the
contact information that's on this slide
and we really look forward to hearing
from you thanks so much everyone
have a great rest of your day